EFETOBORE TASKER: I would say
that I know for me, personally,
this class--
it's one thing to learn physics
in a classroom situation
where you're just
learning or you
have like mathematical
proofs and you're
taking that as truth.
But in this class, you really
put those things to the test,
and you see that, oh, these
things I learned in class
are actually true because I
can see it on a computer screen
that my physical results match
a theoretical prediction.
So I'd say that anybody wants
to replicate this sort of format
at another school--
it's great to have
experiments that
prove simple foundational
physics that you learn
in the classroom just
so the students can see
that the things that they
learn in the classroom
are a real physical phenomenon
that they can observe.
SAARIK KALIA: Yeah, I
think one of the key things
for this class is obviously
just the facilities--
like having the experiments.
But I also think
it's good to have
instructors who really
understand the experiments as
well.
Because a lot of the
times they're just
looking through the lab guide.
It might not be clear
how certain things work,
so it was very helpful to have
instructors around who we could
to ask questions and get
answers that would really
enhance our understanding of
what was actually going on.